lipper les années 60 les ont vu déferler
des années 80 vont les révolutionner un
phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur
mode qui persistent et qui évolue
[Musique]
se trouve en france consciente et avec
un phénomène nouveau c'est le jeu vidéo
et qui prend une ampleur qui même des
bassins petit peu le flipper qui fait
peur ne réagit pas la vidéo va prendre
à qui s'adressent ces jeux ça s'adresse
à tout le monde parce qu'ils sont très
diversifiés et je pense que je pas que
personne se trouvait un jeu au moins
pour lui plaire à quoi ça sert
ça sert on peut dire à rien si ce n'est
qu'ils voulaient a acheté temps là
défouler sur mantes nombre pas la
violence la violence dans les lieux
mêmes des positions non mais c'est un
fait que les jeux sont ils dit à de
toute attaque on laisse couler renault
beaucoup mais
je pense pas que ça vraiment
violent
[Musique]
peu de fabricants en france mais une
dizaine d'importateurs dans les trois
quarts sont en région parisienne
le matériel est essentiellement japonais
et américains rythme de fabrication un
flipper nouveau tous les deux mois deux
appareils vidéo chaque mois chiffre
d'affaires d'un de ces importateurs 70
millions de francs par an avec une
progression de 75% ce chiffre d'affaires
d'une de ces salles entre 15 cents et
5000 francs par le prix d'un flipper
pour le tour de dimitri
[Musique]
il y a deux ans les jeux vidéo
représenter 10% du marché
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié après le
dépouillement avec les flippers
l'adresse et le reflex avec
l'électronique mais le flipper a évolué
et aujourd'hui ils parlent ils chantent
et la partie est passé à 2 francs de
menace plane cependant sur lui la
vignette pour chaque appareil est de 18
enfants à l'heure actuelle pourrait
passer à 4000 francs et un projet de loi
pourrait limiter à cinq le nombre des
partis gratuit
[Musique]